Let’s talk about eggs, baby.
Let’s talk about 2 or 3, let’s talk about
all the good eggs and the bad eggs, and the
ones in between.
Let’s talk about eggs!
Hey everybody, this is Matt Lieberman filling
in for DNews.
I love eggs.
They’re kind of the perfect food.
They’re easy to prepare, they’re delicious,
and they’re packed with protein.
However, a debate has raged for years about
whether or not the yolks, which contain 186
milligrams of dietary cholesterol, are harmful
to your body.
And those fears are justifiable.
LDL, or low-density lipoprotein cholesterol,
puts your body at risk for heart disease and
lowers fertility rates at high levels.
However, HDL, or High Density Lipoprotein
cholesterol, is vital to a healthy body.
Did you know that cholesterol is an important
structural element in the membrane of every
last one of your cells, and also helps create
steroid hormones like testosterone and estrogen?
In fact, cholesterol is so vital to human
existence that your liver produces it on a
regular basis.
Actually, when you consume dietary cholesterol,
you aren’t adding cholesterol to your body
by a large margin.
Your liver detects the change in cholesterol
intake and lowers production accordingly to
keep your body on an even keel.
Now, the long-prevailing opinion of doctors
is that adults should consume under 300 milligrams
of cholesterol a day, and 2-6 egg yolks a
week.
However, there is abundant scientific evidence
that these limits are largely unwarranted,
and that it is dietary fat, not cholesterol,
that raises LDL levels.
In several studies, large groups of people
are split in half.
One half eats 1-3 whole eggs each day, and
the other eats an egg substitute such as egg
beaters.
Over a period of months, egg eaters saw their
good HDL cholesterol levels climb, while bad
LDL levels remained stagnant in 70% of participants.
The remaining 30% saw slight increases, but
nothing drastic.
Also, those that ate pasture-raised eggs enriched
with omega 3 fatty acids saw drops in triglycerides,
a major risk factor for heart disease, and
all egg-eaters saw significant increases in
antioxidants such as Lutein in their blood.
Now it is important to point out that these
studies were all conducted on participants
eating no more than three eggs a day, so I
can’t say with any certainty what would
happen to you if you ate more than three daily.
However, egg yolks are packed with vitamins
and nutrients.
Vitamin A, B2, B5, B12, selenium, calcium,
iron, potassium, zinc, manganese, folate,
the list goes on!
They also contain choline, an important nutrient
that the body requires to produce the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine.
According to a 2004 US dietary survey, 90%
of Americans do not consume their recommended
amount of choline.
Eggs also deliver a fat shot of protein that
has an amazing amino acid profile, including
9 essential aminos that cannot be produced
by the human body and MUST be gotten from
diet.
So, people, in closing, your friend who read
that thing, and then that other thing, and
that other thing about how eggs were good
and bad and good and bad again, tell them
to go suck an egg, or two or three.
They’ll feel a lot better.
So do you feel more confident consuming whole
eggs, or are you still concerned about cholesterol?
Let us know in the comments below.
I’m Matt Lieberman filling in for DNews.
You can find more of my videos over at Sourcefed.
Please like the video and subscribe to the
channel.
Thanks for watching.